not in the mood for an intense 100 hour
plus gaming experience then put down
those controllers in mice and play one
of the many outstanding short-form
experiences available on mobile
platforms
if the likes of a metal gear or which
are like the heavy meals of gaming then
think of mobile games as the quick
refreshing bites the following 5 titles
are what we think are the best mobile
games of 2015
Lara Croft go shares the same branding
as the popular hitman go from 2014 but
the two games of only surface level
similarities yes movement is still a
board game like single spaced at a time
but where hitman rewarded efficiency in
moves Lara Croft goes puzzles require
much more looping roundabout methods to
avoid the game's many deadly traps the
game is a wonderful exercise and
planning and problem solving and when it
comes time to execute
you better have quick reflexes to avoid
any unexpected hurdles thrown your way
reflexes are also the prime requirement
for download and yours better be
cat-like if you expect to have any
success in this challenging arcade
platformer Daniel L is an intense
roguelike that features simple controls
and an equally simple goal survive for
as long as you can as you fall down a
huge well filled with enemies and
hazards gravity is the only constant in
down well but with enough practice you
can begin to control your descent an
increasingly graceful way jumping on an
enemy's head or using a weapon to blast
them out of the sky is just the
beginning and the tremendous feeling of
satisfaction you get after bouncing
shooting and dancing again of multiple
enemies while never touching the ground
is one to be saved defying gravity is
also a key component of Altos adventure
although instead of a dark cavern this
game setting is a picturesque
mountainside where you're continually
snowboarding downhill and this run is a
common place on mobile but Alto
transcends its competitors thanks to
intriguing mechanics that mix pure speed
with a variety of impressive tricks plus
the game is a visual and aural delight
snowboarding at us while the light fades
and the mountain is a joyous experience
and the mood the soundtrack imparts
helps elevate Altos adventure above
others in a crowded genre
when fallout shelter was first unveiled
at this year's e3 many were skeptical of
a free-to-play game set within the
fallout world the game though proved all
of its doubters wrong
filled with the trademark dark humor and
violence the Fallout series fallout
shelter made you truly feel for your
little vault dwellers while at the same
time making you feel like an
all-powerful overseer best of all for
that shelter was a free-to-play game
that didn't have any of the drawbacks of
other free titles if you spent money on
this game it's because you wanted to and
not because the game required you to
neko atsume is an intensely quirky title
that is more than a little strange but
don't let that put you off from trying
it describing the game only adds to its
aura we in this your goal in the game is
to simply attract cats to your home you
can place different items in your
backyard to attract different types of
cats and once the elusive little felines
visit you can take pictures of them and
add them to your scrapbook okay that
description makes the game sound
somewhat dull but trust us when we say
neko atsume becomes increasingly
compelling as you mix and match your
items in an attempt to lure than many
cats as you can once you let nicolette
su-mei sink its claws into you then if
you're anything like some of the game's
fourth crew you'll be constantly
checking your phone to see if any new
visitors are in your yard it's
definitely a weird game but it's an
undoubtedly fun and unique experience so
as you can see it's been a great year
for mobiles for more on the best games
of 2015 then check out the rest of game
sports game of the Year awards
you